wanna know have you guys ever been
cheated on and did you take him back
yes
and yes okay
um
yes and no
i didn't take him back um but i haven't
been cheated on that i know of in my
marriage
um
yes
and
different times different results so
sometimes i have but most times no i
haven't okay
so a second question for the girls
if there was a guy that was taking care
of your bills 100
and you you were taking let's say you
get 10k a month
and you find out that he cheated
but it was it was just just a hoe you
know nothing nothing not in love just
just just sex
would you look the other way
you know what it really depends how the
information had come to me
um and the level of shame involved
but
i would say
if i found out myself like through texas
and or emails or whatever or heard
and nobody else really knew i would
probably just pass it off i would be
fine as long as nobody else knew yeah it
would depend on the level of shame like
if i was like a celebrity and it came
out and it was on all the blogs
it's not happening do you want to
ask yeah go ahead yeah like that so like
it's it's you relate that the
the transgression
how bad it is to how much it impacts you
publicly yeah right so for example if
if it was a case of like oh he just
hooked up with this random girl in a bar
no one really knew about it he might
have confessed it to you in private
you could get over that it's the level
of stupidity that would be involved in
the
like that you have to try and justify
this to your girlfriends your family to
myself and my prior to my ego right yeah
right but if it's not out there in
public
i can justify then you can justify it
but a lot of you which is yeah why i
would argue that it's not justifying it
to yourself it's the level of
embarrassment you put you through
yeah embarrassing you in front of your
friends yeah but not really to yourself
because you without anybody finding out
would stay
because my ego would be able to put that
into check yeah yeah but the
transgression is world series you get
cheated on
i mean sorry the the transgression is
the same it's it's it's not worse just
because more people know about it so
it's really interesting that you
uh it shows i think it's a really
interesting place to start on this
actually i think it shows
i mean my take on this and you know
forgive me if i'm wrong but women sort
of that they are very concerned with the
sort of the appearances of things
and that's almost worse than the actual
pnv side of things if you see what i
mean yeah i agree yeah i think that's
actually an extremely mature
answer to that question honestly that is
i did not i didn't expect anyone to say
that on this podcast i think that's
because it's interesting yeah i'm sorry
to cut you off but i think that's
because all women know
on a core level that
men are like this yeah and if he's
taking care of you fully you're not
going to walk out the door on them
whereas like she said sometimes she
leaves sometimes she doesn't
sometimes a woman will just use it as an
excuse to leave because we know all men
are going to generally do it if
they can man does it you're not going to
leave him because what are you going to
do leave him for a man you love less
than him
that could be that what do you think
what do you think
um
i i'm just gonna cheat on you anyway by
the way say it again he's the the second
guy that you leave for that you love
less he will cheat on you if you can a
possibility it's a possibility i think
but i just don't know whether it's
innately
a man's
disposition that he's gonna necessarily
do that and whether it's like i weigh up
whether it's like
innate or is it society that makes it
all right and allows it and continuously
oh it's definitely not society
women
women of men have different mating
strategies so so men like they want to
spread their same women want to get the
highest value guy possible to reproduce
with so men are more likely to cheat
because like they're trying actually
statistically they're not more likely to
cheat but i would say if men are given
the option to cheat they're more likely
to do it yeah i would say it is innate
in man and i would say the reason
perhaps
more men don't you the reason that every
single man on the planet doesn't chew is
partly because of society and partly
because of their lack of options right i
think most guys stops them i think i
think i think a lot of guys you know who
are sort of you know married guys say in
the uk whatever
um
who are sort of living in a fairly
mainstream kind of lifestyle they're
probably the key reason they're not
cheating is because they don't have the
opportunity or they don't feel that they
have the opportunity and let's say this
is that
a man's inability to cheat should never
be mistaken for loyalty because it's not
not the same thing it's not the same
it's totally different well but how
would you know the difference between a
guy that's just cheating to cheat
because like that's his urge and a guy
that's like
in love with his side chick because i i
think ah because he stops falling in
love with you because here's the problem
we need to redefine the word cheat
okay because
because men
we're really we're really using the
wrong word here because men if given the
opportunity of having the abundance
they're going to sleep with other women
cheating is either emotional
or resources and most importantly taking
resources away from the woman that he is
supposed to love and given it to some ho
that's when a woman really should leave
because any man given the option is
going to do it and a lot of times a
woman a man will trade sexual
exclusivity because he's not the guy
that can get it regardless
so can i just say that not all women
that men cheat with are hoes like that's
exactly
the truth and i just don't like it like
they're being categorized by that
because it's like dehumanizes them and
it's like they're people too so it might
be a woman it might be a woman he also
falls in love with it
might be or just might be casual it
doesn't mean that she's less than yeah
she might not be the connotation of that
word i don't know i feel like if you're
if you're knowingly being a side piece
you're kind of a hoe but something yeah
i mean i'm not talking okay yeah but
we're talking you're you're giving like
the situation where she doesn't know i'm
talking about what she knows now like
that's what i think if you if you if you
just sort of like take a helicopter view
you know you you you kind of just just
look at it from from the highest angle
um everybody is just acting out in their
in their sexual interests right so men
are acting out in their sort of you know
their sexual interest in the in you know
for the best thing sort of biological or
medium evo biological level for them and
women are doing the same thing so yeah
you're correct in a way i mean we
shouldn't really make a moral judgment
about it because people are just doing
what they do right right you know what i
would also add to that
first of all i think you're completely
right
you're right however i'm going to
continue to use a word because let me
tell you why
if i care about no seriously go and go
if i care about my main girl i am going
to ver like from a verbage standpoint
hoe in my mind especially when i'm
talking to her baby's just a hoe yeah
because what she she a woman that's
smart enough to know it's to
and
and if she's smart enough to realize how
the world actually works what she what
she's going to do is she's going to
allow you to trade out what used to be
sexual exclusivity for position yeah and
that means that you're there's hoes but
you're never going to leave the queen
yeah but all that tells me is it's just
a kind of clever way to use language to
manipulate the woman in order to keep
her to stay it's not just language it's
commitment it's love speaking
yeah so but yeah it's just it's just a
manipulation it's just like used like
making women
pitting them herself against each other
basically but she gets she gets more
than she gets more than the verbiage
have you ever made the argument that
a a man doesn't love a woman if he
sleeps with another woman
i've heard it right do you believe it no
i i
i
i just think that men can pretty much do
what they want so i just but you just
don't know i realize it's the man we
pick so i feel like as when we have to
take accountability for the men we pick
so if you pick a guy that's in that top
like five percent one percent whatever
it is like
you can't be shocked when you get
cheated on like if you pick an nba
player like you're going to get cheated
on and also as well it's not it's like i
wouldn't say
i wouldn't say it's manipulation though
in london i wouldn't say it's
manipulation in the sense that the woman
you know
still has the agency to walk away if she
wants she doesn't have to you know he
can say their hoes and you're the queen
and she can say well i don't i don't
accept that phrase so i'm going to walk
away totally i mean nobody's stopping
her from doing that so in that sense
it's not manipulative it's just you know
it is manipulative because there's a
picture she has the freedom sir why does
this get out of the situation okay
that's a good point like but why is a
pecking argument like all of us are
saying because you're just lying no no
no
okay just be honest i think
i think that is more and i want this
girl don't try and be like oh you're the
main but everybody does love her but
that's like don't do a pyramid scheme
literally just saying
i like you as well
you you are fulfilling me sixty percent
but this one gives me 20. and this one
gives me 10 and i've got two others over
there and they give me five each and
then let her decide but the reality is
the reality is for a guy there usually
is one that you like more than the
others just be honest
you're the queen and this one's just a
hoe just be honest and be like look i
want to be with all of these people
are you down or are you not i think i
think that is honestly that is honest so
that's you just said it all yeah you're
the queen
all those women are hoes
no but that is honest i'm not trying to
do this okay are you having do you have
a problem with the words she just
doesn't like that i think i think that
like just
don't try and degrade them and be like
just literally saying i like this girl
and i like to see her on a tuesday on a
wednesday and i like to see this one on
a friday
let me propose something what if what if
instead of him saying queens and hoes he
said queens and princesses
that's degrading to those princesses
personally
that's a bit dodgy like so i'm the queen
and then you have princesses our kids
should be the princesses
that's where i would go with that but
just be honest with you
queens and beauties yeah just say i've
got other women and then we can decide
just be honest give them a name you know
i don't like nameless amorphous
let me get this right um
you're affected by the wording so if
someone was to change the wording they'd
be able to manipulate you into belief no
no just
like really negative connotations and
most times when people have actual
marital relationship sex and what that
is it's not necessarily a woman who is
do you know what i mean like there's
anything wrong with her yeah yeah yeah
do you know what he has like you know
you know what you know what i think i i
think the reason why
sorry to cut you off um
i think the reason why a lot of men will
use this different kind of verbiage
is from there to to get rid of
societal guilt
because men and you you mentioned this
before
uh
you said something something along the
lines of you know do you think society
has this sort of impression on men i
think men
are
under a lot more pressure to feel guilt
for
quote-unquote cheating okay than women
are i think they have
programmed from day one
from things like from obviously
religious things equivalent of women
cheating you say men
have more like feeling more guilt
oh yes i think the average man the
average man like the men on this panel
are kind of an exception to this rule
okay but i think the average man
would feel a tremendous amount of guilt
at even thinking
about sleeping with another woman if he
had a woman he loves with he's in love
with so when you say all men cheat
though like but you're also saying that
they feel a tremendous amount of guilt
so what you're saying is they cheat and
they just feel it i don't i'm not saying
they all cheat
they i'm saying propensity to yeah they
want to they have the desire there's a
desire the urge it's in them it's
violent
that lust right men there's one thing
that no woman can give a man
unfortunately
and that one thing is variety
we're biologically programmed to want
variety and as beautiful as you are as
amazing as you are as a as good of a
mother as you want to be the prettiest
woman the sweet the biggest sweetheart
in the world do everything for me at
some point
i'm still gonna want to have sex with
some strange on the side eventually at
some point she didn't even have to be
that pretty it doesn't yeah
that was the worst day when i realized i
had to worry about the ugly girls too
they're everywhere
hey can you hear me yeah yeah okay
yeah i just
yeah it's really interesting what you're
all saying because from my personal
experience here
like with my partner my partner is out
of town tonight and
for me like i'm
in the best way i can be like i'm aware
that i probably am not the only woman in
his life
i i
i feel like i'm gonna well up like when
i say that but it's the truth and he um
yeah like he's to me the most amazing
guy i'm ever going to get i'm
approaching will be approaching 40 a few
years to go
and if i think that i'm gonna have this
guy all to myself he's my age as well
he's
of high status he does really well for
himself he cares about me he provides
for me he gives me a really really good
life
i'd be like crazy to think
that i'm going to be the only one
it's just not possible you know what's
even you know what's interesting about
that is you don't even know
i don't yeah you've got no idea
it's purely
he does not he does not mention this he
i don't talk about it i don't want to
talk about it okay yep okay
but but this is kind of a this is a
little bit of a lesson for the men
watching
like
it's
not even a fact
it's the
potential of him being able to cheat and
a large part of that also comes into
play when you just told us that he's
a man of status he's high value he's
well to do right lives in a good place
we know that already we talked about it
before right and
if but if he was the opposite of that if
he was some schlub
he'd make any money dressed badly oh i'm
going to like birmingham for the weekend
you probably wouldn't be worried
would you i wouldn't be with him exactly
i don't know they're supposed to know
they're supposed to birmingham though
man
you know what she would you know what
she would probably do she'd probably
leave him for cheating
bingo women do it all the time if he was
lower if he was lower or she would cheat
on him first yep which is way more
likely yep
i mean yeah i mean it's kind of like i
think girls if they know they get a guy
of a certain status will look the other
way and it's it's kind of as long as
they're not embarrassed publicly